bonjour comment allez vous attends j'ai
dû tuer les oreilles des gens bonjour
quand allez-vous moi j'en extrêmement
bien joué aujourd'hui avec cyprien et
seule la frite au cem la frite et
aujourd'hui on joue tamer en slip
attention la version brown et walter est
assez développé par les gars qui ont
fait le nôtre prison je suis très
content absolument on fait ça avec eux
pourquoi un refait une vidéo oui bah
c'est vrai ta mère tu pourquoi on fait
une vidéo sur ta mère en slip parce que
je n'ai fait que de perdre
on a fait deux vidéos je n'ai pas gagné
une manche j'ai jamais fini premier tu
peux ce pas les bonnes questions [ __ ]
mais ma mère m'a demandé ça ça me
souviens alors petite nouveauté c'est
qu'on peut ajouter des cartes
voilà on peut ajouter autant de cartes
que nous le désirons qui sont faits vous
connaissez déjà les règles on a fait
deux vidéos je veux gagner un round je
suis un homme
oui aux français oui de milieux
artistiques et politiques
oui oui je suis nicolas sarkozy non non
emmanuel maintenant oui des musées je
suis dans un endroit
oui oui
en france ou ailleurs wire est une
activité dans ces endroits là une
activité de 2,2 mer-mer c'est bien ça
les mecs ça abusé du pôle bon match je
vais tomber sur un truc genre le
marsupilami j'ai jamais trouvé
[Musique]
je suis un homme
oui oui je suis un homme d'idées pour
rigoler ça va passer mais c'est un homme
d'un dessin animé
il a une tête non j'existe vraiment ça
existe des acteurs malheureusement je
suis chanteur oui oui les gens adorent
mais musique je suis florent pagny je
suis intrigué moi j'estime laquelle je
suis renault pilori je suis juste
charlie situer je suis parano mais
j'aurais aimé être nos jours je suis un
homme
oui est-ce que je suis connue oui est-ce
que je suis peu politique oui mais
est-ce que je j'ai été président non non
pas de la sorte mais ça va oui c'est
vrai j'ai invité pour que tu perdes de
comprendre sinon on va fermer
ouais oui tu payes pour y aller ouais
ouais tu payes pour c'est un truc
de beauté de non non au sein du sportif
pour être beau oui c'est ok je suis
surpris non non je suis keen'v oui ok
j'ai entendu en activité ouais ouais
c'est un sport non sélectivité rôles ou
non qu'ils mais qui fait bien sûr que
ces finitions
c'est chiant red69 monde là est ce que
je suis enfin non est ce que je fais si
jacqueline le premier kit du parfait
homme politique on va parler tous les
mois par tous
manuel valls non non je ne me trompe
non non pas parce que je suis français
non
oui la trouver je suis dans ma jalousie
oh [ __ ] moi je suis emmanuel macron
qui fait une activité sportive nombreux
intérieur wayne aux dents longues c'est
dans l'aube a mis ses atouts coutu coup
et une autre dans l'eau sous une autre
forme
[Rires]
c'est un truc qu'on fait en soirée oui
oui qui devait fume un joint à londres
et one l'alcool non ce qui ne les font
une cigarette
non qu eelv et allume un pétard du
malouin keen'v roule un joint qui ne
verront la joie c'est ça se déroule un
pédo tinevez roland bedouet
mais ça j'aime bien tu vois c'est
persévérer pour réussir bons supporters
allez vas-y tu peux le doublé important
qu'ils jouent une fois dans l'année
c'est pas une fête une fois dans l'année
certaines personnes le font mais kim
jung-un fait l'aïd non non non non c'est
cristal que des stars notre attention
regarde ça va aller très vite
emmanuel macron faites votre diagnostic
fait le badinage non quoi c'est pas sa
survie la somme en jeu cyprien c'est
bien ne pas une patine une patinoire oui
à la patinoire année louis et là
maintenant du coup d'oeil joueur attend
illimité c'est parti là mais bien on
laisse chercher on va bien est ce que
c'est un lieu c'est un événement oui est
ce que c'est la vidéo city assez en tout
cas les natifs
ouais ouais je vais l'avoir attention
les structures bel événement d être allé
en forme et donc qu'ils jouent tous nos
enfants
la première vidéo ça m'a rendu fou vrai
hockey car c'est lui qui perd qui
demandent l'asile
ok est-ce que je suis un homme tué non
non est-ce que je suis chanteuse non
mais tu l'as déjà présenté parce que je
suis pauvre christ et non un sujet si je
peux me permettre c'est fini
[Musique]
ok les gars je suis un homme non je suis
une femme oui oui je suis connue oui je
suis fictif non non je suis l
oui je suis actrice oui tout le monde me
connaît ouais ouais elle ajoute je suis
à jennifer lawrence
non non tu tard je suis plus seul sur
arte non je suis supérieur
non je suis ça je suis un homme
non j'ai une femme oui j'existe non non
non non pas pourquoi tu existes pâte
existe et subjectif je jouais dans un
dessin animé
non non non dans un personnage d'une
série n'ont eu vent d'une seule une
série sur le fait que je dis c'est que
[Musique]
je suis surtout chez moi est ce que je
fais partie de la télé réalité non est
ce que je
[Musique]
oui ils ont dit oui parce que je suis
plutôt triste vidéo l'accroché une
broche la présentatrice météo
donc je suis une actrice très connue
anglaise anglophone non non anglophones
boxe française many non je parle
français dans mes films oui brigitte
macro chez toi lectrice je suis très
connu dans le paysage français marion
cotillard
non non ce matin mélanie laurent est pas
française elle n'est pas française mais
c'est dans ses films elle pas français
mais c'est incroyablement dur là un
petit accent l obstacle savez quoi non
[ __ ] au tabernacle parce que j'aime
aussi question si tu trouve le son
origine ça va vite
je suis un personnage qui n'accueille je
suis une série de films pour les ados
plutôt d'ornon important pour twilight
dans bach dont les barons
south south je suis moi oui je fais une
activité oui oui jouer syndrome on joue
aux [ __ ] mais elle demeure réservé
aux caisses à toi il est insupportable à
chaque halte afin de pouvoir tenir au
but vous mettez des coûts das comitee au
delà alors est ce que un métier un
métier aujourd'hui tu connais très bien
ce métier et youtube oui mais oui c'est
du bon côté ok je suis jolie
oh oui je suis brune oui je suis
espagnole italienne italienne et je
parle français
oui mais mais mais j'y croyais pas je
peux quitter tayenne fin j'ai dit ça au
pis je suis princesse leia et je fais
l'activité oui un sport quand même n'en
retiendra c'est pour serres qui fait un
peu fait bien fait moi j'ai jamais fait
mais j'ai déjà fait oui c'est les beaufs
qu'ils font ouais ouais
oui est ce que je suis tu bosses beauté
non non tu buzz du jour
oui mais que je suis là tous oui ce que
je fais une activité non tu fais le
malin d'activité je suis c'est un état
non non attendez si on est en haut
est ce que je
ok ça c'est moi ok certes je fais un
sport je suis monica bellucci qui jouent
au foot qui jouent au baseball tennis
badminton jouer au croquet jo croquettes
noms qui jouent à lancer une bise sur la
tête de son frère ça fait un bruit drôle
au hockey mais je suis monogame logique
mais [ __ ] mais c'est pas possible mais
que tu es passé tellement de fois côté à
temps plein je voudrais y penses quoi
toi tu me coupe la config ont fait au
camping a partout et on l'a fait fort
match on a bien failli porter jamais
remarqué ne connaissais pas mais depuis
aucune activité à tanger au trader un
peu et après on s'embrouille et indices
et souvent dans une salle des fêtes
rabelais jeleva 80 est ce que c'est la
télé réalité
oui que senna tout qui fait les ch'tis
ouais je suis n'a tout qui fait les
ch'tis exactement oui je suis croyant je
mets une gamme logique fait 1 500 m
monica bellucci qui ferme il met
respiration induction non si monica
bellucci qui fait rêver durant sept mois
à chaque fait et geste rue princesse
leia qui joue au bingo jouer au bingo il
manque un gros et géant messieurs de
quoi tu parles
non attention au bingo j'ai jamais joué
demande sur le jeune homme a déjà fait
le froid quand je fais ce sport
allez c'est parti je suis monnayable je
le fais du ski c'était ok y'a pas un
[ __ ] saucisses et des épices de plein
gré à gré à gré qui écoutez moi bien
celui qui gagne celle là il a tout gagné
mais mais gagne quoi en fait seul jour
où on va
[Musique]
ok go est-ce que je suis un homme oui
oui est-ce que je suis connue oui est-ce
que je suis un dessinateur n'en est ce
que je suis un sportif
non non est-ce que je suis un
concessionnaire
je suis marseillais non d'un bébé elle
mais l'expert de faire ça je suis un
homme
oui je suis je suis réel à tanger cl je
suis mère gigabyte
non je suis un acteur je suis un homme
politique oui chez emmanuel macron non
c'est dans la tête c'est kim jong-un non
non sa mère je suis raffarin je suis
nicolas sarkozy oui mais voilà sarkozy
qui fait tourner les serviettes
[Musique]
je suis un homme que c'est non non non
mais tout ça pour battue et il ya doute
chez une femme oui mais tu diverti les
jours en france
oui oui sur you tube non non mais vous
l'avez ya pas longtemps elle avait
beaucoup changé mais tu peux le faire et
ce à cause de lui que le quai toutefois
je te dire lundi chamond il a fait une
polémique de fou aux monstres ou simple
mais incroyable et dont philippe et doit
primer les sahraouis qui date des années
2000 strauss kahn non et dominique
strauss kahn mais puissant de foucque
beaucoup plus puissant owen times avait
battu 6-1 abbas est dommage pour apaiser
cette partie wahaha
ok je suis nicolas sarkozy je fais un
sport non je suis un endroit je suis au
ski non non c'est sur un télésiège
non vraiment un endroit genre est dans
la salle de classe ça pourrait être sa
mue saision le même ok il y en a en
france
il est à paris il à paris ok je suis
nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée o le fils de
gpt mon doigt sur cette tablette mais
c'est ouf
c'est comme si le destin voulait que je
gagne la partie qui fait gagner tout pas
une femme
oui qui divertit et longtemps elle est
vieille elle est décédée non non non à
l'amérique son activité on a fait mais
plus tard la télé on a fait mais au ces
troubles c'est loana est ce que vous
mmes accepté d'acheter ni son prénom
tels que tu mettes inquiète harvey
weinstein c'est validé est ce que c'est
un truc qu'on fait quotidiennement
ouais ouais
moi je le fais énormément est ce que ces
manifs et des ponts heureusement tu vois
bien que non parce que seven stones qui
touche une femme view
je suis une femme ça fait longtemps que
l'objet les comédiens n'ont pas fait de
la télé réalité non un du champ oui oui
elle est chanteuse oui fallait pas qu'il
revienne c'est elle est parvenu en fait
j'avais ressenti au kenzi go est-ce que
c'est chiant que motivés aussi agréable
quand tu le fais mais autour les gens
ils font
j'ai pas l'ont fait plusieurs fois dans
cette vidéo français ira là-bas mais
c'est gentil
albert einstein qui paie un nom albert
gougy la maison albert bichot d'albert
et servez je suis laurie non c'est même
période dans la mana peut guetter opus
puisque itochu diam's oui s'il est bien
de ça qu'il a vraiment arrêté permet à
stein en train d'émettre un signal
sonore non enfin deux c'est ce qu'il
fait une activité liée au web
[Rires]
c'est arrivé go je suis frustré je vous
sais pas si nos dessus diam's est dans
un endroit très particulier a partout
dans le monde ne sait pas gérer le droit
n'est pas particulier mais l'activité
les tatouages jamais fait mais dont je
vais c'est une activité non web avoir
tout pris 6mois divertissement s'amuser
mais aussi du plaisir s'il se dit que si
on met alors au chant à la recherche de
plaisirs d'un speed dating baby i'm the
speed dating
comment t'as fait comme en recherche de
plaisir j'ai gagné à les albères et à
bernstein m'a dit laisse donc hervé
weinstein
c'est une chose que vous faites souvent
marche pas je leur fais souvent hélas
pas s'en remettre c'est un toc c'est un
toc et les gars hyper dur non ce sera
dur franchement ça va m vous êtes des
bâtards sa mort enfin je suis dernier
weinstein qui
qu'ils y allaient qui joue notamment
n'ont eu je suis hervé vannes stein qui
je suis dépité dans le cas oui le
meilleur moyen de clôturer cette série
de vidéos était de gagner la game qui te
fait tout gagné exact merci à tous les
gars le jeu m'a un peu aidé choix qu'il
a lui-même eu pitié de moi n'hésitez pas
à passer voir la chaîne de sem qui va me
dire nous a fait le plaisir de nous
procurer un fou rire colossal vidéo fait
savoir la chaîne de sic n'hésitez pas à
aller sur le ps store ou l'app store
pour télécharger le jeu c'est amusant
dans l'est que donner un euro et alors
par exemple dans la queue d'un
restaurant ya rien à faire tu le sors
c'est génial bîmes dans la queue au pôle
emploi il ya rien à faire je regarde les
gens autour de toi tu le sors tu
t'amuses à décembre approche film il ya
du monde au cdi il ya beaucoup de monde
il sa bouche mais ça crée une petite
queue dans la queue du cdi dans la queue
du cdi débat vous abonner tuant tout le
monde
ok
c'était combat